Bueno, vamos a meternos de lleno en esto.
En diciembre de 2026, Chile va a vivir uno de los cambios normativos más profundos de
toda su historia digital y financiera.
Hablamos de la entrada en vigor de la Ley 21.719.
Y ojo, porque esto no es un simple parche administrativo, para nada.
Es una transformación absoluta que pone el estándar chileno al mismo nivel que el famosísimo
Reglamento General de Protección de Datos Europeo.
En este análisis vamos a desgranar exactamente qué significa este cambio tan monumental
poniendo el foco en los datos que mueven la economía actual y, sobre todo, en esos
nuevos derechos que van a cambiar para siempre las reglas del juego entre las organizaciones
y nuestra información personal.
A ver, para entender realmente la magnitud de esta ley, tenemos que hacernos un par de
preguntas clave.
Imaginemos la siguiente situación.
Alguien pide un crédito y un sistema automatizado se lo deniega en cuestión de milisegundos.
O, por otro lado, una deuda comercial antigua por fin cumple su plazo legal de prescripción.
Hasta hace nada, enfrentarse a estos escenarios era meterse en un auténtico laberinto burocrático.
¿Pero qué pasa exactamente ahora bajo este nuevo marco legal?
Las respuestas a estas preguntas son el corazón de la normativa y, básicamente, reescriben
los límites de lo que las empresas pueden o no pueden hacer con nuestra información.
Y aquí viene el punto crucial.
Las reglas del juego ahora tienen un árbitro de verdad, con sanciones que asustan.
Hablamos de multas máximas de hasta 20.000 unidades tributarias mensuales por infracciones
gravísimas.
Eso equivale a miles de millones de pesos chilenos.
Una auténtica locura.
Además, se crea la nueva Agencia de Protección de Datos Personales.
Una institución autónoma y con poder real para fiscalizar y multar.
O sea que las organizaciones ya no se enfrentan a un riesgo teórico en un papel, sino a una
autoridad totalmente activa.
Para que todo quede clarísimo, en este análisis vamos a recorrer cuatro áreas fundamentales.
Uno, la biometría y los datos de alta sensibilidad.
Dos, el derecho a impugnar decisiones automatizadas.
Tres, el fin de las bases de datos con deudas prescritas.
Y cuatro, el nuevo estándar de cumplimiento.
Así que, empezando por el punto número uno.
Biometría y alta sensibilidad.
Hablemos de esa información que, a diferencia de una contraseña cualquiera, es imposible
de cambiar porque forma parte de nuestro cuerpo.
La Ley 21.719 cataloga la biometría como un dato sensible de nivel máximo.
Pensemos en los famosos procesos KYC o Conoce a tu cliente, que usa tantísimo la banca
actual, donde nos piden reconocimiento facial para verificar quiénes somos, o incluso algo
tan básico como fichar en el trabajo con la huella dactilar.
Tratar una huella, un rostro o la voz ya no es un simple trámite técnico.
Es una operación de altísimo riesgo legal que exige muchísimo cuidado.
Entonces, la gran pregunta es, ¿cómo se tiene que gestionar esto ahora?
Pues la ley se pone estricta.
Antes de encender siquiera la cámara o el lector de huellas, es obligatorio hacer una
evaluación de impacto en privacidad.
Hay que medir el riesgo antes de actuar.
Además, se exige aplicar la privacidad desde el diseño, lo que en la práctica está
impulsando soluciones interesantísimas como el Edge Computing o procesamiento local.
Fijaos.
Si el reconocimiento facial se procesa en el diseño, la ley se pone estricta.
Si el reconocimiento facial se procesa en el propio móvil y esos datos no viajan a
la nube ni se guardan por ahí en servidores externos, el riesgo cae en picado.
Pasamos al segundo pilar, impugnando decisiones automatizadas.
Y esto es interesantísimo.
Hoy en día, todos sabemos que los algoritmos de inteligencia artificial toman decisiones
por nosotros constantemente.
Y claro, ahora están bajo una lupa legal gigantesca.
Pensemos en el scoring crediticio automatizado.
Si un modelo de IA evalúa un perfil de riesgo y decide rechazar un crédito de forma automática,
eso tiene un impacto jurídico enorme.
Y lo mismo pasa con los sistemas que descartan currículums en recursos humanos o los algoritmos
de precios dinámicos.
Y aquí es donde el artículo 8bis introduce un cambio que es brillante.
Se acabó esa impotencia de recibir un no automático dictado por una máquina.
Ahora nace un nuevo remedio legal, el derecho fundamental a no ser objeto de decisiones
basadas únicamente en algoritmos.
Esto nos da el poder directo de impugnar un resultado y exigir que un ser humano, de carne
y hueso, revise el caso.
Para no pillarse los dedos, las organizaciones que usen estos algoritmos tienen que implementar
tres pasos innegociables.
Primero, transparencia absoluta.
Hay que avisar de que es una IA la que decide.
Segundo, explicabilidad.
Hay que poder contar de forma sencilla qué lógica ha seguido la máquina para llegar
a esa conclusión.
Y tercero, revisión.
Tiene que haber un canal rápido para que una persona real evalúe las quejas.
Ignorar esto al diseñar una app de finanzas es, literalmente, buscarse una multa.
Vamos con el tercer punto clave de este análisis.
El fin a las deudas prescritas y la limpieza de los registros comerciales.
La contundencia del texto legal en este apartado es espectacular.
Si pensamos en bases de datos tan conocidas en Chile como Dicom, el artículo 17 lanza
un mandato radical.
Los responsables de estos registros financieros tienen que suprimir automáticamente la información
sobre deudas prescritas.
Y ojo a esta parte final.
Sin necesidad de mediar solicitud, orden judicial ni instrucción de la autoridad.
Es decir, es una eliminación activa, obligatoria y por defecto.
Para que veamos la información, vamos a ver un ejemplo.
Veamos cómo cambia esto la vida real.
Tradicionalmente, cuando una deuda prescribía, empezaba un calvario de juzgados y papeleos
para intentar borrar ese registro, algo que a veces era peor que la propia deuda.
Con la nueva ley todo esto desaparece.
Al cumplirse el plazo legal, la entidad que gestiona esa base de datos está obligada
a purgar esa información de sus sistemas, de forma totalmente automática.
La conclusión que tenemos que sacar de esto es rotunda.
La costumbre de acumular y guardar datos históricos por si acaso se ha terminado.
El principio de minimización manda ahora.
Si un dato ya no tiene base legal o su propósito ha caducado,
retenerlo indefinidamente es una vulneración directa.
Todas las bases de datos comerciales van a tener que programar políticas de purga automática sí o sí.
Y llegamos al cuarto y último bloque, el nuevo estándar de cumplimiento corporativo.
Sabiendo todo lo que hay en juego, aquí tenemos la hoja de ruta práctica para adaptarse.
Primero, hay que levantar el RAT, el Registro de Actividades de Tratamiento,
para saber exactamente qué datos hay y por qué se tienen.
Segundo, lanzar evaluaciones de impacto cada vez que haya un riesgo alto, como usar biometría o IA.
Tercero, fundamental, montar un canal ágil para responder a los derechos ARSOP,
acceso, rectificación, supresión, oposición y portabilidad en el plazo legal máximo de 30 días.
Y cuarto, aplicar siempre la privacidad desde el diseño en cualquier proceso nuevo.
Para cerrar este andálisis nos quedamos con una reflexión importantísima.
La privacidad ya no es ese aburrido texto de términos y condiciones que nadie se lee,
sino la arquitectura misma sobre la que se van a construir los sistemas financieros y tecnológicos del mañana.
La fecha límite de diciembre de 2026 está a la vuelta de la esquina.
Las reglas están claras y las herramientas existen.
La verdadera pregunta que queda flotando en el aire es
¿están realmente las organizaciones preparadas para rediseñar su futuro digital a tiempo?